やあみんなドーゲンここにいるので、これは
日本の財政のフォローアップビデオです。私は
約1時間持っているので、
すぐにそれに飛び込みたいと思います。私が行かなかっ
たいくつかの質問をさらに調べたいと思います。
私は
このビデオで質問に対処する
だけなので、私の質問
を詳しく説明するために、日本で誰かがどのような収入保護をしているのか、
私の財政の質問を始め
ましょう。 あなたはパフォーマンスを
管理
する必要がありますあなたが賃金からだまされないことを保証する強力な雇用法法の州の機関があります
人々は一般的に冗長パッケージを持っています
か？ それ
は一つの質問なので
、それは本当に仕事次第
だと思いますが
、企業
がほとんどまたはまったく気付かずに従業員を解雇することはますます難しくなっていると思います。
これまで日本
に行ったことがありますが
、ちょっとした
ことや、大規模な
警告など
で問題が発生したことはありませんが、他の人と一緒に仕事をしたこと
がありますが、誰もが解雇されるのを見たことがありません。
特に、
私が2、3のように働いたために働いていた大企業では
、上司
が会社
を引きずって会社を引きずっていたので、上司が人々を解雇したいと思った例があったことを知っています。 その人
を雇うための投資の見返りが得
られず
、多くのお金を失っていたので、これらの特定の個人を解雇したかったの
ですが、私にはわからないので、彼らはできませんでした。
おっしゃるように法律や代理店
でしたが、その会社で設定されたの
は、誰かの前に一定期間にわたって複数の警告が広められなければならなかったというプロセスがあったことを私は知っ
ています
解雇される可能性があるので
、
この
特定の質問についてはあまりよくわかりません。保険収入保険についてはわかりませんが、
石油にお金を払えば、これはあなたにとって良い情報になる
かもしれません。 これは実は所得
保険
ですが
、日本のほとんどの大手企業で
支払う失業保険に加入すれ
ば、1年半だと思いますが
、2期の最低支給額だと思いますが、
あなたが1
年半の間それにお金を払うなら、あなたが解雇された場合
、その会社が廃業した場合、または
あなたに何かが起こって
あなたが失業した場合、
すべての主要都市に こんにちは、
職場のようなものです。
まるで雇用のようなもの
です。英語で説明する方法がわから
ないようなものですが、
政府が後援
しているようなもの
です。失業者が
雇用されるのを支援する政府機関です。  再びオフィスは
すべての主要都市にあり、仕事を失った
場合はそこに行き
、失業保険に加入した場合は、毎月の収入の約
60％を取得する資格があります。
一年半一年半
払わなければならなかったの
か、一年半
もらえるのか、頭のてっぺんから思い出せないの
ですが、実際に受け取ることができると思います
前の仕事で一定の最低
期間働いていた場合、最大1年半の支払いが行われるため、
実際には1年
半以上かかる可能性があります。
数年から3年ですが、そうですね
、政府は
、人々が
失業したり、解雇されたり、何かが起こっ
たり
した場合に、いわば路上に出ているだけではないようにしようとしています。
日本のフライを食べていたものがあります nds私はもう彼らとはあまり
連絡を取り合っていませんが
、そのうちの1人が実際に仕事を失ったことを覚えています。
彼らは古い仕事を辞め、
失業保険に加入したとは思いません
が、彼らが仕事を辞めたときのことを覚えています。
彼らが最初にしたことは、彼らが
ハローワークオフィスに行ったことです。そこに行くと、あなたは
それらの支払いを受け取るためにセットアップできるオフィス
だけでなく、基本的
にあなたができる複数のジョブリストのようなすべてのジョブリストを持っています
すぐ
に申し込んで、私は仕事
をしていないと言うので、これらは私が持っているスキル
です。
おすすめと、失業した友人
がその
事務所に行って、新しい仕事に
就きました。こんにちは、仕事が終わって数か月だったと思います。
日本語では、ハドルウォークと呼ばれ
ています。時間を確認させてください。 私はそのタイムスタムを置くことができます
そこにp大丈夫6mmm約
6分大丈夫
ええハドルハドルウォークは
日本語で呼ばれているもの
ですそしてあなたが外国人でさえもそれらの支払いを受け取ることができる
ので私
はまたこんにちは仕事に行って新しくなった外国人を知っています
その代理店を通じて仕事をし、また
こんにちは仕事に行くことによって彼らの失業と保険の支払いを受け取った
ので、それはおそらく
その質問のかなり良い答えだと思うので
、財務の質問に移りましょう
それでも、
交通機関にはどのような選択肢があり
、車、
自転車、スクーター、電車、フェリーなど
、私が考えられないすべてのものにかかる費用はどれくらい
か疑問に思っています。別の代替質問があるので、私
は代替であり、 私は限られた予算を持ってい
ますあなたの予算と節約のヒントは
何ですか私は請求書の世話をすることができ
ます
彼は2番目なので
、あなたはまだあなたの配置を知らないのですが
、前のビデオで私が言及した
ことは、彼らがジェット
プログラムになるということです。
非常に
状況が良いので、それは本当に
あなたが前にいた特定の場所に依存します
以前のalt
はそこで働いていたので、たとえば私
は私の近くに住んでいた303のaltを知っていました
私たちはお互いに約数マイル以内に住んでいる
ので、
たとえば私の前任者
は、私が教えた学校の代替であった男が、
彼が前任者から使用した
と信じている彼の車を追い払おうとし
ていました そして
、その前任者
はそれを新しく購入したか、それが数年前に購入した直後に購入したと思います
が、私
がそれを手に入れてしまったとき、私の最初の私たちは
おそらく私について支払っていたでしょう
千ドルの2000ドルはわからない
けど、前のビデオで言ったように日本に来たときは
本当に
バイクが欲しかったので
、雨の中などで通勤したかった
ので、250ccを購入しました。
ニーン・カワサキ・ニンジャ
は、私が日本に来たときに最初にした最初のこと
で、かなり手頃なバイクですが、私の
古い前任者は
、彼が日本を離れていたので、彼の車を追い払おうとしていたので
、ちょっと言った 車を救って
もいいですか、すみませんが、このバイクを購入している
ので、本当に必要ありません。
彼は
、この車を処分しなければならないので、販売します。 あなた
は200ドルであなたはそれを買うでしょうそして私は
確かにそう言ったので私は古いものを手に入れました
それは本当に古い種類のまともなビーターでした
私はそれの用語を忘れました
15歳ですが、結局
$ 200で手に入れました。これは、
おそらく少なくとも15
歳の私にとっては問題ないことです。 とにかく私
は本当に安い車を手に入れましたが
、私と同時に入った別の代替品は
、前任者が持っていたために彼らが手に入れた車のために1000ドルのような痛みを
もたらしました
彼らは
日本で4
年ほどLTにいて、たくさんのお金を節約していて、
彼らが計画して
いたので、その車をかなり新しく購入しました。正確には覚えていませんが、彼らは
その車をかなり新しく購入しました。 だから私の友人
のLTは私と一緒に来てその車に
1000ドルか2000ドルのように支払わなければなりませ
んでしたがええとそれは
非常に状況的
です 50ccのスクーターは実際に50ccの
スクーターでAPUに通勤していたの
ですが、もしあなたが
仕事に十分近く、スクーターで行くことができれば、
それは素晴らしい選択肢だと思います。
特にgに帰国したときのスクーター o私の古い教育の
仕事に行き、後でAPUに行きますが、ええ、
私はその新しいものを$1000の
ようにおそらく$1300のように購入し、毎日それを使用しました。
効率
がとても良いので
、スクーターの使用をやめることができる状況にあるなら、
それは本当に本当に
費用対効果の高いオプションなので、費用対効果が高いです
ええ、それはお金を節約しようとする良い機会です
、そしてそれは実際
に 2番目の質問
も次の質問にあり
ます予算が限られているLTあなたの予算
と節約のヒントは何ですか私が請求書の世話をすることができ
ますあなたがすでにELTであるならあなたは
おそらくあなたの すでに交通機関が
あり、新しい車を買うことを心配する必要はありません
が、スクーターは新しい車
を手に入れること
ができ
、基本的に5人全員にとって間違いなく信頼できるので、来ている人にとっては素晴らしいオプションです。 年
ジェットプログラムで最大5年間、それ
は良い投資ですが、あなたが
すでにaltである場合、これは
私にとってもう少し難しいです私は一種の孤独ですそして
私はこれについて前に話しましたが
基本的にずっと 私はジェット
プログラムに参加していて、
勉強や執筆のように部屋に閉じ込められたままだったので、あまり外出せず、また外出もあまりしなかったので
、かなりの金額を節約することができました。
たくさんのお金を使うし、
食べ物の値段なども意識的に質素だっ
たので、
安いお米をまとめて買うことが
できる小さなこともたくさんあります。 大量の
オートミールは、
オートミールを立てることができれば良い選択肢があります私
はオートミールがとても好きですが、ええと、
発酵大豆も発酵大豆ではない良い選択肢
は超超健康的であり、
どこでも購入できる超超安価です
スーパーマーケットや自宅の
ビーニー、またはそれが1つのことかもしれないところならどこでも
ホメニの
コミュニティは、一般的に、1回の食事の
ようにそこに行くと、かなり安いように見え
ます。そうすると、1つのBentallセットなどを知っ
ていますが、通常
は、より新鮮な同様のBentallセットを入手できます。
スーパーマーケットに行くことでより健康になり、
GTや新しいものを所有する
こともできます。そのため、おにぎりはその会社のおにぎりのように
なりますが
、通常、中には保存料のようなものがたくさんあることを知っています。
通常、地元のスーパーマーケットのスーパーマーケットでさらに安くて健康的なおにぎりを手に入れることができる
ので、それは
私がお勧めすることの1つです。
まだ騙されていた頃は
、オートミールを入れたプロテインプロテインシェイク
やピーナッツバター
などが好きだったので、
liを作るのに良い方法でした。 あなたがいる
なら他の良い選択肢を手頃な価格で提供する超簡単な食事
あなたが日本に長期間滞在しているならおそらくすでにこれを理解しているでしょう
が、あなたが最初
にやりたいことの1つは 通勤
のために電車を書かなければならない場所で
は
、通勤パスを毎回購入するのではなく、通勤パスを8枚取ってもらい
たい
ということです。通常、そのトラックで一定の長さの通勤パスを購入する方が安いので、これ
も親切です。 ほとんどの人はそれを知ってい
ますが、そうでない場合は、それは別の良い
ことです。あなたがすでに日本にいる場合にお金を節約するため
に私が考えることができる他
のヒント
前のビデオでこれ
について説明するのはあまり良い仕事ではなかったので
、お金を投資して節約することは
本当にあなたの精神についてであり、
それは
つまり、あなたが
累積的な興味について学んだら そしてあなたがどれだけ多くの
お金を稼ぐことができるか
あなたが物事を見る方法を本当に変える
少しのお金を持っているだけで、基本
的にどれだけ多くのお金を
受け取ることができますか？
そのドルで2、3セントではないにしても、少なくとも1セントの権利がほぼ再びある
ので
、前のビデオで再び話した高金利の貯蓄アカウントのようなこれらすべては、2パーセントのように提供します
または、
ほとんどのアカウントで2ポイント25パーセント2ポイント3パーセントで、
私はそれ自体でその数だと思っていることを知っています。
それほど意味はありません
が、100ドルを知っている場合はそれを意味します。
そのアカウント
では、年末までに
さらに2ドル、
1,000ドルの場合は、さらに20
ドル、そのアカウントに1万ドルの場合は、
200ドルまたは $ 300 depe 保険
料を調べて、あなたが
それを大丈夫だと考え始めたら
、この取引でこの取引のためにもう1セントがあれば
、個々の
セントは最終的には ドルそして
あなたがその人形を手に入れたら、あなたは
その次のセントの権利を得る権利があります。それは
基本的
にあなたができるところならどこでもお金を
節約することです。
本当に
あなたの精神をどれだけ変えるかを強調することはできません
、そしてあなた
が100ドルを持っているだけであなたが100ドルを持っているなら
あなたは質問なしで2ドルを得ることができます
そしてあなたがそれを理解しそしてあなたが投資のある種の力を理解
すると もう一度、その2％は
、はるかに多くの
金額になります。あなたが持っているお金が多ければ多い
ほど、その種のギアが
回転
し、自分のペルソナでお金を節約できる方法を考え始めます。
l人生とあなたの行動の仕方
そうそうそうそうそうそうそう
そういうことで、カップル
が
投資してより多くのお金を節約することに興味があるなら、彼らのライフスタイルを再評価するようになるかもしれません。
それが私が持っていたすべての質問だと思います
前回のビデオの準備ができたので、投稿後にビデオで受け取っ
た質問とコメントに移行してみ
ます。そうすれば、一体どうやってETFが最善の選択肢であるかを誰かが言ったので、私は 前のビデオ
でETFの上場投資信託について話し
ましたが、個人的に
はETFが最良の選択肢だと思います。
なぜなら、リスクのレベルが異なる非常に多くの
種類のETFがあり
、何もない超高リスクETFのようになることができるからです。
しかし、
非常にリスクの高い株式が含まれている可能性
があります。ETFには10の株式しかないことを知っているかもしれません。一方、Vanguardが多くの
ETFを提供しているように、
それらはすべて高リスクです。
単一のETFのアメリカのすべての株式のように、ETF
は
、
投資家が多くの研究をしなくても、あなたとすべての個人投資家
が探しているリスクのレベルを提供するので素晴らしいです。 お父さんと
私には2人の子供がいて、結婚してい
て、コンドミニアムにお金を払う家
があります。投資はもう少し保守的
ですが、私が独身の場合
、または独身の人の場合は、あなたを知っています。
ETFはその種の個人にとって最善の選択肢ではないかもしれませんが、
やはりリスクの高いETFもある
ので、実際にはすべて
特定の状況に依存しますが、 私は彼らが
うまく働いているので
大丈夫です申し訳ありませんが私は質問を探してい
ます多くの人があなた
がとても体重が減ったように見え、
あなたはホームレスのように見えます
彼のええええ
私のひげは成長しました 前のビデオ
で本当に専門家ではないように見えたら
申し訳ありませんが、これは良い
質問です。
日本に移住してアメリカ市民権を廃止してみませんか。
これは
実際には私には言えませ
ん。 真剣に検討しています
が、この問題についての私の考えをお伝えします。
前のビデオでこれについてもう一度話しましたが
、IRSが
海外に住むアメリカ人にとって
報告の面でどれほど複雑になるかは好きではありません。 毎年米国政府にあなたの収入がある
ので、私
がアメリカ
市民でなければ、各
時代がかなりの時間を節約でき、
さらに
彼らがフラットのようなグリーンバック税務サービスを持っているので私は節約することができます
再びの料金私は毎年約450ドルだと思います
私もそのお金を節約することができ
ましたそして私がすぐに10のように権利を与えられ
ている追加の450ドルを持っているという理由だけで私が保険で以前に話したものに再び戻ることができます
基本的にもっとドル
なので、実際に合計されるような小さなことを知っています
が、
私がアメリカ市民の市民権を放棄することを真剣に考えてい
ない主な理由は、私がお父さんで
あり、私であるためです。 責任があり
ます。つまり、私は日本に住むのが大好き
で、一生家族と一緒にここに住むつもりですが、
何かあったとしても、日本との
大きな対立のようなものはわかりません。
そして
周辺諸国や
日本の株式市場に大規模なクラッシュがあり
、それが
どういうわけか私に影響を与えることになった場合、私
は日本の株式市場に投資していないのかもしれませんが
、世界中の人々がそれを見るかどうかは
わかりません もう日本に引っ越したくないと思うかもしれ
ませんもう日本を
勉強したくない彼らは
私のビジネスに影響を与えないので、
私がアメリカ市民権を保持し続けている主な理由
は
私が今まで持っていた場合 州に戻るために
私はそれを簡単に行うことができますそして私は
私のアメリカ市民権を持っているだけで私の家族を連れて
行くことができます私の女の子は両方ともそれを非常に簡単に得ることができますそしてあなたは私の妻にとっても問題がないことを知っていますそれ
が主な理由です そして、私は
アメリカ人であることを非常に誇りに思っ
ています。アメリカが象徴していた元の価値観がとても好き
です。これも少し
政治的になりすぎているので、実際にはその道を進むことはあり
ません。 私がアメリカ人であることを誇りに思う主な理由私は
日本も大好き
ですが、何かが起こったとしても少し複雑だからといって、まだそれが
なかったらアメリカに戻るのは難しいでしょう。
繰り返しになり
ますが、
それは他の何よりも保険証券のようなものです
ええ、私は政治的に大丈夫にならないようにもう一度そこに置いておきます
ので、投資口座を開設しようとしていました
が、私も
引っ越す予定です 今年の7月に仕事のために日本に行く
のでこれ ビデオは
、来年東京で海外に出かける予定で、税金を準備するとき
に何に注意する必要があるのかを知りたいと思っていま
す。 翌年は大丈夫です。
留学しているだけで
アメリカに帰国
する場合は
、日本で何らかのパートタイムの仕事を
するだけで、得た収入はすでに
課税されます。
両国に税金を払う
必要がない
ので、米国に申告しているだけなら何もする必要はないでしょう。
とにかく米国での申告は、
留学しているだけなら、日本で地元の仕事を
しているだけなら大したことではありませんが、
オンラインでの仕事のようにたくさんやっているのなら
、 日本に
送金できない場合は、州からお金が発生
しているので、mとして持っていくと 初めて日本に
来たときに必要なだけのお金を
送って、後で送金するのを避けることができ
ます。そうすれば、物事がずっと楽になりますので、できるだけお金を送らないようにしてください
。
すべてがはるかに簡単ですすべてが
はるかに簡単です。なぜなら
、地元の収入だけを受け取っている場合は税金が
すべて処理され、送金する必要がない場合は、
TurboTaxなど
のファイルを作成することができます。 あなたが稼ぐ収入
は州から発生し、
日本には送金されないので、送金し
ないようにしてください。あなたが
言ったウェブサイトへのリンクを追加できますか？私は
非ネイティブです
リンクを追加しなかった主な理由は、リンクがビデオに含まれ
ていても、指で問題が発生したためです。
お詫び申し上げます。
申し訳あり
ませんが、大丈夫ですl
日本とアメリカの両方から課税されませんか？
これを計算したと
思いますが、それだけの価値はあります
が、米国市民であるというメリットを維持することは価値があります。
国ええ、私は誰か
が私のためにこの質問に答えましたが、私は両方の国から課税されていません
私は唯一の問題のいずれかによってのみ課税されています
私は米国に私の税金を報告しなければならないということです
税金を読み返して
も、
500ドルも450ドル
も払わなくてはいけないので、ちょっと前に話したのです
が、そんな
煩わしさは私が手放すには十分ではありません。
アメリカ市民権と
それに伴う保険
とても大丈夫素晴らしいビデオ素晴らしいビデオは
、最初に米ドルに変換せずにインタラクティブブローカーのようなウェブサイトに直接日本円を投資することができるかどうかを知っているかどうか疑問に思っ
ていました の
日本それは可能
だと思います。私が言う理由
は、ここに地方事務所があるからです。
正しく覚えていれば
、アカウントを作成するときにそれらが異なると
思います。主な通貨を指定する必要があると思います。
それ
を使って投資することになります。
日本人も普通の
日本人も彼らと一緒に口座を作ることができると思います。
アメリカ人はすべてのアメリカ人
が社会保障番号を持っており、すべての
外国人はすべての日本人
と外国人だと思います。 日本では
最低時間を忘れています
が、基本的に
は社会保障番号に相当する日本人
がいます。インタラクティブなブローカーアカウントを作成するときは、その
情報に日本の社会保障
番号を入力する必要があります。
ええと
、あなたがそうするセクションがあるので、私は
日本人がアカウントを作ることが可能であると想像し
ます、そしてそれ故に私は 米ドルに換算せず
に、あなたに換算せずに直接日本円に投資することは可能です。
うまくいけば、あなたの質問に
答えることができます。このビデオに感謝します。私は
安全で友好的な質問に答えようとしています。
私は米国ではありません。 市民多分私
は日本の株式市場や
ブローカーを追いかけて別の種類のETFを買う
ことができますが、そこに質問がなかったことを残念に思うことがたくさんあり
ますが、コメントをありがとうございますこんにちは私
はあなたがまだ騙されているのだろうかと思っていました
騙せたらいいの
ですが、時間が足りず、
少し年をとっているので、関節が以前
のように動かなくなってきて
いるので、
行くのが少し危険です。 バックフリップのようなことをやっていて、以前の
ように大丈夫だと思い
ましょう。
本当に高度な質問がありました。このビデオは
私の操舵室のすぐ上
にあり
ます。コメントに追加した後、コメントに追加します。  mは
1つを見終わった 私が特に
興味を持っているのは
、日本で購入した不動産の借金を取得する方法です。
私はすでに日本でいくつかの不動産を購入しまし
たが、米国市民であるため、現金での購入に制限されてい
ました。 投資
物件なので、10年間日本に住んでいなく
ても、これらの物件にローンを組むことができるかどうか聞いてみたい
です。内容のおかげで、
この質問に具体的に答えることはできません
が、問題に関連することがいくつかあり
ます。 簡単に触れておきたいの
ですが、以前の
ビデオ
で、日本でコンドミニアムを購入することについての以前のビデオの1つについて少し話していたかもしれませんが、
日本では、不動産の価値
は通常、
少なくともどの主要都市で
も時間の経過とともに上昇する米国では、
兄がシリコンバレーに住んで
いて、彼はコンドミニアムを持っているか、そこにコンドミニアムを持っている
と言いました。
すでに
20％以上値上がりしていると思います
が、日本では
逆ですが、私のようなコンドミニアムのよう
にゆっくりですが、時間の経過とともに確実に価値が下がっていく
と思います。
その理由
は、前回のビデオでお話しした人口危機ですが
、日本での土地自体は大丈夫な投資かもしれないと思いますが、
投資
の形で住宅やコンドミニアムのように購入
するのは良い考えではありません。
時間の経過とともに価値が下がっても
、引っ越しを決意した場合の価値
は、
すでに同じコストのアパートだったので、それは私にとって良い考えだったと思います。 私
がこの場所に支払っているのは、
月額費用であり、二度と目にすることのないお金です。そのため、不動産を購入する
ことが
間違いなく私の最善の利益になると思った主な理由をもう一度知っ
ています。 日本ではですが、私は
あなたの質問に本当に答えることができません もう一度投資
するという観点から、日本の不動産をどのように活用するかについて
私は
個人的に日本の不動産に地元の投資をしません。
他の国、特に米国
では、他
の投資タイプの一般的
な投資との相性が良いので、たとえばETFの別の例
のように、不動産不動産ETFのようなものがある
ので、私は実際
に私たちに投資しています 米国のような不動産市場
不動産も同様
です。ETFには複数の種類があるため
、単一のETFには
、市場に出回っている個々の家
や商業ビルのような不動産や建物が少し所有されていることがわかります。 そして
そのようなものなので、私は
もう少し保守的だと思います
が、それは潜在的に良い
選択肢だと思います
あなたがすでに日本に持っている物件
はおそらく日本人を経由する
ことであり、私はその特定の問題
についてこれ以上アドバイスを提供することができ
ないことをお詫びします。
おそらく月に約1,500ドルのよう
に大丈夫か
、以前に話していたものに戻って
、少なくとも1セントまたは少なくとも1ドルと1セントを節約することは常に可能で
あり
、1ドルはそうではありません
個人的にも多くの人がそう
思っていても意味がないと思いますが、そうは思わないのですが
、東京ではお金を節約するのが非常に難しいので
、IIがお勧めする理由の1つであり、
以前のコンドミニアムの購入に関するビデオもあります。 そして
、日本での生活や東京以外での生活で
は、東京の
すべて
が日本の他のどこよりも高くつくのは非常に難しいの
ですが、いつでもコストを削減
でき、いつでも何とかしてお金を節約することができます。
東京の真ん中でそれは本当に
本当に難しいですが、月に5600ドルの
ようなさまざまな住宅オプションのようなものを知っています。
それらは基本的
に東京の中心部にあるので、
驚くほどではありません。 シェアハウス
やその
ようなものですが、投資が私である場合、彼らが人生で何をしようとしているのかという点で、あなたがそれぞれに再び投資することにコミットしているなら、それらのようなオプションも常にあります
彼らにとって重要かどうかはわかりません
が、組み合わせて大丈夫です。これは
興味深い質問です。日本に定住することにした場合、私の家族は私
たちの貯蓄を日本に持ち込むことに課税されます。
いろいろな要素が
関係しているので、例えばあなたの名前は
日本人以外の名前な
ので、例えばあなたが
日本人と結婚していて、あなたや
何らかの形で彼らを通して日本に貯金をもたらすことができれ
ば、 貯金を日本に持ち込む
ことで実際に課税され
た場合は、
自分自身や
外国人のパスポート所有者のような他
の場所で行った場合とは対照的に、おそらくあなたはより少ない支払いをすることができるでしょう。  m言いたい
ので、その質問の正確な答えはわかりませんが、
申し訳ありませんが、申し訳ありませ
んが、これ以上お手伝いする必要
はありません。日本に送金するときに課税されません。
ええ、私の会計士はそんなにプロバに言及したことはありませんが
ブリーではありませんが、私はすでに
日本の所得税を支払っているので、
大丈夫と言うのは少し難しいです。それ以上詳細に
答えることができないので、先に進むつもりです。
ほとんどない英語の教師に投資することをお勧めしますか？
ええと、
もう一度始めましょう。これは
、最初に述べたものに戻っているだけ
ですが、はい、いつでも
より多くのお金を節約できるので、それ
があなたの最優先事項の1つである場合は、その節約の見返りを得る
ことができます。
優先順位なので、
そのお金を使って現在のライフスタイルを楽しむので
あれば、もっと力があります
が、私の娘の1人が目を覚ます
1秒申し訳ありません申し訳ありませんが私の女の子
は目を覚まし続け
ます このビデオの残りの部分で少し静かにしようとすると、
ビデオの残りの部分
でもう少しビデオに入るかもしれませんが
、最後のコメントで私が言い
たかったのは、それは常に可能であるということです
ほんの少しの金額でも投資する
ので、前のビデオでこのビデオ全体で話していたこれらのこんにちはオンライン
利息口座貯蓄口座のほとんどは
、最小残高として1ドルしか必要とせず
、もう一度1ドル持つことで可能になります あなた
はそのドルで1セントを得ることができます、そして
再びトリックはあなたが
利子から1セントを得る
ならあなたが毎日行うすべての取引で10セントを節約することができるのでこの1セントは重要ではないことを理解することです
それがコンビニではなくスーパーマーケットに行くことによるものであり、一般的
に少し質素であることを知っているかどうかにかかわらず
、それは
そのアカウントに1ドルだけを投資して1
セントを得るのではなく、おそらくそのアカウントに2ドルを持っている可能性があることを
意味します そして2セントを持って
いますそしてそれはあなたが1日で正しく作ることができる違いですそれで
あなたが3パーセントを得ているならば長期的に物事を考えるならばo  r
2％保証さ
れ、将来的に
10万ドル
を獲得できるようになると、そのアカウントに10万ドルを持っているだけで、2千ドルを獲得できるという
権利は与えられなくなります。 あなたは
あちこちで少しのお金を節約する
ことができるので、投資する価値がある
ので、投資が
あなたにとって重要なものであるなら、
それはおそらくこのビデオでも良い点だと思います
私はそこですべての質問に答えたと思います
私
が2つのポイントに対処したかったもう1つのポイントは、多くの
人がビデオが
転送によって後援されていると尋ねます、そして私が
スポンサーをすることになった場合は絶対にそうではありませんでし
たが、彼は
彼らのサービスのために転送が賢明でした
PayPalよりもはるかに安い
ので、私が楽しんでいる会社やサービスを推奨し、宣伝
することを強く信じてい
ます。 私自身を含めたユーザーは
、その恩恵を受け
て、長期的にはさらに多くのお金を節約できる可能性があります。
たとえば、
2か月前、おそらく3
か月前に
、国際送金の方法を変更したと思います。
すでに
PayPalよりも大幅に安かったのですが
、さらに安くなるように変更された
ので、それが再び発生した場合は、
それが私の最大の関心事であることがわかり
ます。 あなたの中には
それからも恩恵を受ける可能性があるので、私
は後援されていませんでしたが、私は転送が大好きです
、そして2番目のことはあなたが計画しているならあなたが言及
しなかった一般的な1つのこと
は通貨リスク
です 日本に
長期滞在し、ドルで支払われる
場合、10
年以内にそのお金が必要になり
、ドルをに送金する場合、米国の普通預金口座にそれらのドルを入れるのは危険かもしれません。 日本の円
への投資貯蓄口座からの余分な関心は、当時と現在の
ドル/円の為替レートの
違いによって一掃されるかもしれません。これは
非常に良い点だと思います。この種の
ことは私が話していたものに戻ります。
私
は長期的に日本に住むつもりです
が
、アメリカ人として地元に投資する方法がないので、保険の形として
アメリカ市民の市民権を保持するという点で以前は、妻を通して少し投資することができ
ますが 私の会計士によると、それはあまり効果的な選択肢ではないので、特定の時点までだけであり
、それはあまり有益ではあり
ません。
したがって
、一般的に、
日本の証券会社、証券会社、
会社
、そしてすべてのロボ投資家
ロボ投資
私が知る限り、日本に存在するアプリや
ものはすべて、米国の
競合他社よりも大幅に高いレートを持っているので、私の
curでは 私がやっていることを
やって
、州から州に戻ってこれで稼いだお金を投資することは
おそらく最良の選択肢ですが
、それは確かに私に将来のために考える何かを与えてくれるので、このコメントに感謝します
たぶん
私がやることになるのは
、それらの投資の一部を日本
に移し、妻を通して少しだけ投資して、
大部分
が米国にあるようにすることですが、あなたが言ったよう
に、私が今までにそこにリスクがあるので
すべて日本に戻り、
為替レートを変更したいのですが、少なくとも
日本でもこの少しのお金を持っているので、米国
への投資ほど速くはありませんが、
これも成長すると思います。 これ
も良い点です。申し訳ありませんが
、そのビデオの大部分を切り取らなけれ
ばならなかったのですが、おそらく
7分から8分ほど失われたので、
このビデオの現在の長さは
おそらく40分程度かわかりません。 だから
多分45分 基本的に
、日本の財政の観点から言い
たかったことはすべてですが、まだ数分あるので
、チャンネルの最新情報をいくつか紹介したいと思いました。私の怪我
など、次のビデオはオプ
ションです。 私が今考えている次のビデオで
は、
日本の発音を勉強するために日本の発音を教えるために使用するさまざまなリソースについて話し
ているので、このようなリソースの長所と短所について話すように教えています
これらのさまざまなリソースと私は私
が話しているこのような10または15冊の本を知らない
ので
、ビデオオプション番号1であり、
次にビデオオプション番号2は
一種のセットアップツアーを行って、
私がビデオを作るために使用するプロセス
とそのビデオでは、実際にはそのビデオのごく一部
がハードウェアと実際
の部屋について話し、私のスタジオや
そのようなマジョのようなものについて話します
私はこれまでこの種のトリックに戻ってきたので、ソフトウェアの側面について話します
が、その1つは
、トリックの世界
に彼の名前がgieux jiwoo fooであり、
現在は
彼は現在Instagramで非常に人気があるような、Instagramの個性は
、100万人のフォロワーがいるなど、
彼はかつて騙されたコミュニティの主要人物であった場所で
あり、今でも
確かにそうですが、すばらしいブログを持っています。
私が非常に長い間フォローしていた
こと
、そして私が言いたいのは、
彼がおそらく4年前に
、キーボードショートカット
が私の人生をどのように変えた
かというタイトルの記事を書いたことです。
それを
活用して生産性を
向上させる
ために使用し、最近は自動化に取り組んでいるため
、Alfredのワークフローなどのサービスや
キーボードショートカットなどのアプリケーションを使用しています roを
使ってコンピューターを作り、
定期的に行う必要のあることを行う
には、私がいないときでも時間がかかるので
、そのビデオでもそれらについて話します。
実際、私はそれについて話すことに非常に興奮して
います。
ビデオを見る大多数の人
にとっては新しい情報になると思うので
、今は2つの選択肢があります。それは
日本のリソースか、ルームツアー
とソフトウェアツアーのどちらかです。
どのビデオを見たいか教えてください。
2つ目は、私が
医師のところに戻ってMRIの取得について話
しましたが、彼はMRIではなく、神経損傷の可能性がある身体検査であるかどうかを確認するために一連の検査を行いました。
私はおそらく10から10の
異なる検査をしませんでした、そして彼はこれは
神経損傷のようには見えないと言いました、そして私
たちがあなたの症状に基づいてMRIを行ったとしても、
私は何も現れないと信じています、
そして私はしません
あなたのようなarのためにMRIを行う方が良いかどうかを知ってください
これらの神経
または腕自体のために首の部分を丸めているので
、まだMRIを取得していませんが、これは
おそらく私が抱えている問題の1つであり、
おそらくRSIと呼ばれるものである
ため、反復運動過多
損傷です。 基本的には、あなたが
指を使い
すぎて、コンピューターの仕事のように少しやりすぎていることを意味します。
私にとっての問題は、私が
あまりにも多くのことをしているということではありませ
ん。 私の赤ちゃんを
常に特定の位置に保持するようなものを組み合わせてコンピューターの仕事をする
こととストレスは
それと関係があると思うので誰かがコメントを残し
ました あなたが抱えているストレスのせいで、
比較的十分な睡眠をとる日に
は症状が大幅に改善することに気づき
ました。さらに、これは
私が言及したかった要点の一種
です。 誰でも  同様の症状があるかもしれません
が、私は
行ったことがあるので、数回鍼治療をしまし
た。最後にそれをしたときは
、日本で少しかわいいと知られていることもしましたが、それを
どのように翻訳するのかわかりません。
私が見たすべての翻訳は本当に
奇妙だったので英語ですが、本質的にそれは
伝統的な漢方薬の
一種であり、それらが少しのように置か
れていますそれを説明する方法さえわかりません
それは少しのようです
包まれた伝統的なハーブや
ある種の草のようなものが
燃えやすいラッパーで包まれて、それはあなたが皮膚に直接
付着するいくつかの接着剤で粘着末端のように
なり、それからあなたは
それを火につけますそして
物の間に少しスペースがあります それ自体とあなたの
肌は火傷しませんが、それ
はその特定の領域を非常に
非常に熱くしますそれはほとんど
あなたを火傷するようですそしてそれをすることによって
あなたの白血球をその
特定の領域に集中させますそして私は私がいないことに気づきました それ
をやった後、
行ったあき鍼灸所の
症状が少し
良くなったので
、回復したわけではありませんが、症状は以前ほど悪くはありませ
んでした。 家から
使えるものをたくさん買った
ので、毎晩寝る前に
、あちこちの関節と
腕の一部にそれらを置いてみました。
それらすべてに火をつけてください、そしてそれは大きな炎や何かのようなものではありません
それは
ほんの少しの種類の火傷ですが、それを
することによって私は
物事が悪化するの
を防ぎ、物事を
悪化しているが、状況
は最悪の場合ほど悪くはない
ので、誰かが再び同様の症状を示している場合は、
これ
は日本語でもう一度調べること
をお勧めします。
時間を確認して出発できるようにします
氷の日焼けだから1時間大丈夫私は
ここに日本語を残し、それから私
も翻訳を残しますので
、あなたが望むならそれを調べることができます
それが
今日私がカバーしたいすべてです 日本の財政に関する
この種の
2部構成のビデオシリーズの恩恵を受けることができ
ました。次のビデオでカバーしてほしいの
は、リソースなのか部屋のセットアップなのか、
ソフトウェアツアーなのか、その他の長期的なものなのかを教えてください。
この種の長い形式のモンドコナントカラで私がカバーしてほしい他のトピックは何
ですか？日本で
何か-このビデオの
ような日本の財政を知っている
か、日本で日本語を勉強しているか、それとも
外にあるかもしれません ふりがなや
発音などもありますので、ここ
でも取り上げてほしい一般的なトピックを取り上げたいと
思いますので、ここで切り詰め
ます。今後ともよろしくお願いいたします。
すぐ